hey guys i'm alex
just at hot dogs i'm a home cook
maryland girl
so today i'm being challenged of making
three different meals using one random
ingredient and i don't know what it is i
have a bowl of like 15 ingredients of
i don't know what i'm cooking so i'm
going to pick okay
okay
oh i can't see this it's plantains
yes i can do this i'm puerto rican i can
do that
plantains i make plantains all the time
so let me think
because girl i don't know but okay let's
get
thinking of ingredients
[Music]
i have all my ingredients i got some
eggs
it's early here it's almost brunch
so i can make like a hash or like uh
some plantains oh i could do like a
frittata
oh i never had that before that's good
okay
i'm preheating my oven to 400 degrees
i'm going to cut the plantains
toss them in some olive oil and some
salt
and let them bake until golden brown
because we want them to get golden brown
they gotta be tender and good crack 10
eggs
and toss them in some milk nice and
fluffy
toss them with some salt and pepper heat
up some olive oil in a pan and your cast
iron which i hope you
season in oil i'm going to saute
some smoked spicy sausage which is bomb
so once the sausage is done i'm going to
remove it from the pan and set aside
next saute some peppers and onions for
about three minutes until soft
add the garlic and tomatoes into the pan
as well you don't want the garlic to
burn garlic burns super quick
all right we gotta add it in girl
add it in so we're going to reduce the
heat to low
add the egg mixture oh
yes there's a lot of eggs child
oh you want the little edges to start
getting golden
and crispy did you season it i hope you
seasoned it too with salt and pepper
top it with the plantains that have
already been golden brown
transfer it to the oven for about 15 to
20 minutes
just until the eggs are barely set
it's gonna be good oh she's cute
[Applause]
yes some salt some
cilantro she is cute
oh my god and some avocado
avocados from mexico
she is cute she is very cute
looks profesh i like it okay i'm gonna
taste it
this is good it gives you like sweet and
savory
for breakfast this is bomb
[Music]
oh my god am i smacking i think i am
smacking we're just coming up with this
on the spot i'm shocked
i'm very proud of myself i'm gonna take
a break because i'm getting full
we're gonna come back for dinner because
this is a big piece of frittata for
breakfast
and i'll be back for dinner okay
cheers to saturday ow
cause i'm about to get turned okay so
i'm back for dinner
i feel like this is going to be a lot
more simple
i guess because i'm half puerto rican
i'm going to do my mom's famous pikachu
and i think i'm going to stuff it in
plantains because i always cook with
plantains but we're going to use a
stuffed version
so we're going to make the plantain like
a little boat so we're going to
peel it and cut a slit down the middle
and make a little boat but don't do it
like all the way so it goes all the way
through
because you want the little meat to be
in the banana boat
oh my god like a banana boat banana boat
okay plantain boat
place it in a baking dish with some
butter
covering foil because you want them to
get real nice and soft
and plump and sweet in a cast iron pan
or skillet we're gonna heat some olive
oil and saute the onions and peppers
until soft about
two to three minutes you can take a
drinking break
like me we are going to add garlic until
fragrant
add the ground beef break it up add your
sazon
and cumin and worcestershire
whatever that sauce add our chicken
stock and a little bit of tomato sauce
to thicken it up
add our diced potatoes because of starch
and then we're going to add in the
olives for a little bit of acidity
that's key olives are key in puerto
rican food
don't forget that one other thing you
need
to check for seasonings we don't do
bland food in this house
you need to check if it's seasoned
properly with salt and pepper
but taste your food that's the best part
stuff for me when my mom makes this dish
it smells of just like peppers and
onions and like you can smell the sauce
on
like and that's like key in puerto rican
households but we're switching it up
this time because we're making a little
plantain boat
we're gonna add some cheese to the
bottom of the pan make it stick
and then we're gonna put the meat
mixture which is done
in your little banana boat and then
sprinkle with cheese
and it goes back into the oven to melt
and
gooey goodness and all of that warm
about this
i'm gonna garnish her with some cilantro
it's
cute so pretty it's delicious
oh this smells good it smells like my
mom's
kitchen it smells just like when she
used to make it
okay
[Music]
that's good it's fun and the cheese sets
it off
set it off is that a song i make
breakfast
i make dinner we have to make dessert
because i have
one more dish to make so first up
because i am not a baker unless i'm
drinking
so we'll see how it goes all right
so last meal of the day i need something
sweet
and i've been drinking i'm gonna phone a
friend
like who wants to be a millionaire i'm
gonna call my mom
my favorite person in the world because
she can give me some tips
hi honey hi okay wait so i need
some help what's going on okay
so i'm doing this challenge where i have
to
cook three dishes right
using one ingredient but it's plantain
and you know that's my favorite i love
plantains soft ones the soft ones yeah
the sauce
obviously the sauce right okay but i
don't know what to cook for
dessert because like i don't i don't
even ever
yeah i know somebody that that did it
with um they
they sliced they had to be the um the
really ripe ones
yeah i hadn't wait yeah the right one
yeah
because she's gonna slice them put them
in the oven and she would put like um
she would sprinkle a sugar and cinnamon
put it in the oven to bake like i can do
like a banana foster like a plantain
foster
yeah that's a good idea i like that okay
i think i can do that
right i can do that okay okay okay mommy
i love you
i love you too okay i love you more
i love you more i love you bye
okay so we just talked to my mom so she
came up with
plantain foster i've never done this
before
so i feel like it's gonna be good it's
like banana foster so it should be good
so let's get cooking and i get to use a
torch
we're gonna add butter and brown sugar
to a skillet and you're going to
constantly stir until it becomes this
thick nice golden brown syrup
you know like the color of our melanin
skin
you'll see it so next is cinnamon a
pinch of nutmeg
and our plantains they're gonna get real
syrupy and
drenched in the goodness cook the
plantains until they're nice and soft
for about three to four minutes until
they're golden brown
the best part add rum and light that
[ __ ] on fire
i thought i got my whole apartment on
fire
but i'm making banana foster but
plantain foster
i highly highly suggest use a long
kitchen
lighter because we want to be safe and
you don't want to
burn your apartment down okay so
once it's safe and the flame burns out
you're gonna spoon
over the sauce on the plantains you want
it to get
nice and softy and reduced for about two
minutes
the best part serve with ice cream with
some crushed
nuts whatever you want so shout out to
my mom for giving me the tip
to make plantain foster so i'm gonna
taste it but the ice cream is melting
oh it kind of smells like cinnamon toast
prince
this is good the cinnamon you can taste
the rum
my favorite part i am exhausted i made
three dishes using one ingredient
plantains which is my favorite i'm half
puerto rican
now everything was good but i think the
plantain frittata was the best
i've never made that before i'm super
impressed i'm going to serve it at my
next brunch party
chef's kiss thanks for watching i'm alex
just add hot sauce find me in brooklyn
find me on instagram do it again alex
okay hold on okay i'm sweating
thank you for watching i'm alex just add
hot sauce
find me on instagram or instagram i
don't know why i said it like that thank
you for
watching alex say it okay thank you for
watching
i'm alex find me on instagram just add
hot sauce or in brooklyn if you're in
new york
cheers see you later
oh yes
you